[Music]
all right
let's go and that's another black game
we agreed against e4 to play a night off
so we're going to stick to that
and bishop c4 something we have faced
a million times as our
you know during our five minute speed
run and as we know the best way to start
is to play knight c6 this is the most
flexible
now as i explained to charlie the
easiest way to understand why this is
not dangerous
is because we haven't pushed our e pawn
yet when you play e5
and black white plays bishop c4 that's
the italian here you can play e6 in
order to blunt the bishop and make it
bite on granite this is very simple
now you can follow up with d5 but you
don't have to rush with d5
that move isn't going anywhere what i
like to do here is first develop my
knight and maybe lure went into going e5
himself
because then you're going to go knight
q4 and win the punt now
it's time for us to go d5 expand and
grab control of the center
eded we've got phenomenal position if he
goes here he'll lose a piece
a lot of people do that there we go
um so this is a super common trap
and i would call this a level two trap a
level one trap
and what what is the could somebody give
me the whole sequence here because it's
not what you guys might think
it's not what you guys might think
because if we give queen a full yeah
queen a5 check he sees for sure so he
thinks ah
will i go knight c3 cover the check and
defend the bishop what he's missed is
the move d4 after that d4 wins the
knight
so a level one trap would be a situation
where
this wins a piece immediately level two
trap
okay he sees the basics but now he's
spotted that t4 wins the piece
these games are not competitive at all
well actually doesn't
i think he can save the piece but he'd
have to really bend over backwards
well it's just how it happened today a
lot of these games have gotten more
competitive
i think when we cross 16 1700
we'll stop winning games so quickly but
it's not a bad thing i think
every game has its place
okay so knight c3 d4
bishop c6 bc and let's see if he finds
the way to extra yep he does
he does find the way to get his knight
saved i didn't see this initially before
now it's not a good thing
he attacks our queen and he cuts into
the pin so he plays c takes b4
and now his knight is free to move
however
he's going to lose at least one punt
probably two
and his position is going to be
miserable so good job by our opponent
finding
very nice uh defensive resource
all right so let's get the order of
operations right this
tension between the knights there's no
reason for us to keep it right
he wants to take on f6 and ruin our pawn
structure so let's begin by taking his
knight that'll simplify our task
now how should we proceed here because
it's there's a tempting move that
doesn't do as much as it looks and then
there's a good move
which does perhaps more than it looks
so you guys are falling for the tempting
move the tempting move
is b3 b3 looks good right it looks like
an edgy
discovered check but after bishop d2
you can play bc and after queen takes c2
white is fine and white's going to be
attacking that c6 bone
so i like people's suggestion of bishop
a6 to stop castling but i don't think we
need to overcomplicate it
i don't think we need to overcomplicate
it we are up one pawn what
is the simplest move in the position
forget about bishop a6
the simplest move in the position the
greediest move in the position
is to simply take another pawn b a check
look at this beautiful pass bond a3 even
if we lose it
uh well we're going to be up we're up
two pawns and here comes queen d2 that's
a blunder
it's obviously a blunder uh so
we got fortunate here but even without
it white is essentially lost and i'll
explain that after the game
and we've had a couple of quick games
that's just how things go sometimes
yeah that's that's going to end it
immediately
okay so here it's important not to get
way laid by the rock or try to be fancy
let me take the rook first we take the
rook we drop our own queen nope we take
the queen with check
we keep our eyes on the prize and now if
you want to play clinically
you should anticipate that he's going to
castle
so well queen b5 he goes rook b3 and
chases the queen again
so in addition to queen b5 where else
can we put the queen to create a threat
where should we put the queen to create
a threat no it does this is gonna be the
last game guys
i'm already staying longer than i was
planning to
okay some of you considering queen chief
have a queen g5 he can castle remember
that his next move is probably going to
be castles
so we need to look at all of the
undefended points in his position and
then decide
which of them is going to be most
attackable very nice queen c5
this is the most clinical of course
we're up a queen and it really doesn't
matter where we put the queen
but this hits the pawn it hits it where
it hurts if he castles
we hit the pawn we take the pawn on c2
and well it's over
boom and also we're paralyzing his
development
his bishop can't move and well it's just
it's just over
so you can see we're we're we're keeping
the
foot on the gas pedal we keep the
pressure
keep the pressure going goes knight f3
that's a good move okay so he's
attacking the pawn
it would be unwise for us to go d3 here
because it would enable him to blockade
the dark squares he could go bishop d2
and rook c3 you see how the dark squares
become weak the queen could get stranded
so instead a more patient and more
measured move would be to do what
we could castle here that would be a
simple move but but the ambitious move
is to play c5 connecting the pawns
making sure that
his pieces are kept at bay yes nice very
nice
yeah bishop h3 after castle is just
another random guy there was a rook on
a3 that could have swung
over and taken that bishop i know what
you're asking all right now we need to
resist the temptation to take on e4
obviously because it puts the queen and
the king on the same file
allowing rookie one pinning the queen so
time for us to castle
rookie one all right there's many
approaches to winning the game
i always propose to complete our
development when possible this bishop on
c8 where should it go
where would be a good way to put where
would be a good square to put the bishop
on
e6 is fine yeah but should be six
totally fine don't go bishop basics that
blunt is the bishop
but i like the concept of bishop b7
attacking the pawn
what i like about this move not only
does it attack the pawn immediately
but if you play z5 we're able to take
and snap off this knight
which makes the win a lot easier in
addition it's just a nice
you know out of the way square we can
take the pawn immediately
we can also bring the rook into the game
kind of
soft pinning the night if the night
moves we take the pawn of the rook
all right this is not very scary
although it's a good it's a good effort
one thing i would refrain from doing is
going f6
f6 maybe he can go knight d7 and he'll
start threatening some sort of tactics
so i think it's a good time now
to snap off the spot on e4 bishop takes
e4
and the reason i'm not overly breaking
things down here is because anything is
winning as long as you're moving in the
right direction
you're bringing pieces into the game
you're taking pawns and stuff
it doesn't matter at a granular level
what you're doing
so now i noticed that we could
we could counteract his influence on the
g-file with a timely bishop g6
bishop g6 would be a very solid move
just to make sure there's nothing
no crap that happens down the g file so
let's do it
and he's probably going to go rook c1
that would be my my
guess and then we have a nice
simplifying idea that just wins the game
on the spot
yeah okay okay what is this
simplifying idea yeah you guys are
already spotting it
i've advised many times when you are up
a lot of material don't go crazy with
like giving stuff up just to simplify
but here
we can we're not even really giving
anything up we're giving up a queen for
a rook and a knight
and we end up up a full rook with a
bunch of passponds this makes the wind a
little bit easier so this is a good
example of giving up just a tiny bit of
material
but greatly simplifying the winning task
it's always a balance now i
would advise to make some luft you know
if you're playing like a bullet game
particularly
just go h6 so you don't have to worry
about some
dirty move coming later here you know
we're in the hands of a professional so
i'm going to refrain from that and just
go c4 it's time for him to resign
c3 d2 all right
let's bring the rook into the games
supporting the passer from behind
check and we're going to make a queen
and that's going to be checkmate and
that's going to result it's going to be
resigns
okay we're well on our way to 1600
that's great
that was a simple game uh good job by
our opponent he was pretty resilient for
sure
and i've i think i've seen charlie win a
piece like this a million times you know
bishop b5 is an instinctual move
he should bring the bishop to a2 in
which case we can bring our bishop to g4
and then complete our kingside
development
and uh yeah nicely done here bishop c6
and b4 is the correct approach
but knight e4 uh allows unnecessary
simplification if i were white i would
just drop the knight to e2
to target the d4 pawn and to make sure
the center remains closed
so some of you are proposing bishop a6 i
think that's a very interesting move
but it requires unnecessary calculation
he can play queen takes d4 you're giving
up upon
and it's it's harder than it seems to
create threats against his king because
now if you take he's got bishop d2
and yeah you can play queen b5 you can
build a battery
yeah i know this is good this is this is
a very good idea but
maybe he drops the queen back something
like this things get a little bit heated
here so
that would be possible but b takes a3 is
simpler
we win a second pawn we check his king
and he should have gone bishop d2 and
now
if you guys are how should you think
about this position well
again there's two approaches you can try
to prevent him from castling
which is something i don't think is
necessary because you've already won two
pawns
you have what you need to win the game
you don't also need to try to
maneuver your queen and do too much what
would be a good square for the queen
which is
a sort of out of the way and b
supervises both of these pawns
how should we continue here with black
what's a good square
so bishop before you guys are some of
you are blundering the pawn don't give
the spawn up for no reason
and i didn't mean that aggressive queen
c5 i don't like
because it you know it it makes it
harder for us to develop the bishop and
it's just it's there's a little bit too
much traffic here
there's a little bit too much traffic in
this area of the board
one thing that could happen is he could
go bishop c1 and attack the pawn again
we want the bishop to have its eyes on
the pawn
so the square as some of you are
indicating is queen to a4
queen a4 that's a brilliant square it
pressures the pawn defends this
defends this and the queen is virtually
unassailable
the pawn is an umbrella you guys can see
how nice the queen is on a4
castles we could go c5 to support the
pawn not necessary yet
i like the move bishop c5 then we cancel
and a very simple plan in this position
let's make some random moves for white
would simply be to go a2 and then
support that pawn with bishop b6 and
eventually
try to dislodge the rook from a1 he's
totally paralyzed white has zero
ideas here it's a straightforward
[Music]
i i keep uh interrupting the chord with
my feet
the the queen is a very often
misunderstood piece these squares like
a4 you want to
really look for those kinds of squares
where the queen is
out of the way it's hard to attack but
it's doing a lot
it's doing a lot despite seeming to be
in the corner
queens don't quite work like knights
they can do just as much from the side
of the board as they can from the center
for example in fact they can do more
okay um and i think with that
we're going to well if c3 you can trade
queens i i mean you're you're up two
pawns in an end game
you can just trade queens and go for a
position like this
right okay easier said than done
obviously i know that
everything i say is easier said than
done i'm here lecturing you guys about
all this stuff and i don't do it myself
so
you know that's that goes without saying
any questions before we wrap up for
today
about this game or about anything in
general we'll take a couple of questions
the dark knight thing for the 500.
i'll open the floor up if you guys have
general questions and stuff couple
minutes is good with me just a few
if people have questions when will i be
back so
just to recap what i said at the start
tomorrow i will have to go to sleep
early
non-negotiably i'll have to be in bed by
by 8
39 p.m and uh
you know i have candidates commentary
friday i can't be tired for that
and i can't have bags under my eyes i
still will but
i've got to do my best so tomorrow i
will try to be back
either in the morning or around 3 p.m
eastern i'll do a
i'll do an afternoon stream and uh we'll
we'll we'll um we'll do some blitz and
stuff
okay let me let me check if people have
questions
what is the best pawn to use for luft
asks ryan so ryan the
the general answer is the h fun right h6
is the most inoffensive way to create
luft
it's the least weakening if you go g6
you generally weaken
more more squares right per capita
but it depends and one of the things
that people don't always realize
uh just as a quick very quick uh final
tutorial here
that's a great question so i i do want
to tackle it
you have to exercise your judgment um
in the sense that you know if you have a
position like this
right you have a situation of this
type if you have a situation of this
type
and you're playing black and imagine
that there are other pieces i don't give
a
damn about where white's king is or
where the other pieces are
but this is what's important and you
you're seeing the bishop on d3 and you
say well i want to create some luft
and you play h6 that's a pretty myopic
approach because you have to anticipate
that white's going to go e5
and you know the bishop's going to now
control h7 and
you've created luft in name only rook
uh you i'm sure people have fallen into
this a million times i've fallen into
this [ __ ]
a million times um i allowed myself a
little
indulgence there so this might be a good
example of
when g6 is a uh is a good move
uh right this is a good example of a g6
is a good move
but i will make a further
complicating point which hopefully is
more than a complicating point
in end games there is a particular kind
of move
which grandmasters make automatically
but
people often don't quite understand and
the purpose of this move i'm going to
say that immediately
is essentially to hold down
your opponent's pawns on what's one side
of the board
so let me try to give you an example
let me see if i can think of an example
so i think there was this
game oh i have a phenomenal example
we'll end with this
but this is a phenomenal example i've
given this to my higher rated students
it's complicated
but i'll walk you guys through it i need
to grab a book that i know this is
in so i'll be right back and this will
be a good way to top it off i think
so the book i brought is called
mastering
end game strategy by johann helston
who's a swedish swedish grandmaster i
think now works as a coach
uh fantastic boy he wrote mastering
middle game strategy and mastering
endgame strategy it's sort of a pair of
books
it's these are good books i use them
more as
reference books to give my students
material and stuff
it's it's a hard book to just like read
cover to cover it it's long
so you know it's it has great material
and uh it's got it's got some really
really good stuff um
he also remastering opening strategy now
he knows what he's talking about so this
is good stuff
uh and there was one example here that
really i found to be very instructive
um and let me see if i can remember who
played that's the one problem i
don't remember who just playing this
game let me see if i can
reconstruct this i i'll do a megabase
search because i remember
where some of the pieces were okay
so this is
a game between two grandmasters like
mcnabb is a scottish jamers and alice
the lithuanian guy
and you get this position this this
doesn't seem at first to have anything
to do with luft
because the king is not on the back rank
but it's a similar concept
so essentially
well what's going on here who's playing
for an advantage
the first thing to notice right the
material count is that black is up upon
black is up upon which may seem to give
black you know excellent winning chances
but if you look a little bit more
carefully
you you run into a problem which is that
white threatens to win the pawn back
and black doesn't seem to have a good
way to defend against that
i'm just flipping to this moment in the
book
155 382
[Music]
yeah there it is
so if for example you play b6
who can spot white's defensive approach
here what's the purpose
what what what does white do here why is
this a draw ryan five
gifted damn girl thank you
thank you ryan i appreciate it so it's
not b5 guys there's a much simpler
defensive approach check
check and uh sir
where is the king going you can't re
well you can go to c6 but white starts
mopping up these pawns
and who knows what's going to happen
this gets crazy right
so it's going to be perpetual the king
can't escape
the checks that is white's threat so
the idea that most of my students came
up with
when i gave them this position and i i
saw a couple of people suggest this is
rook d3
and rook to d7 this makes sense the
problem
is that you've made your rook very
passive and although white has some
minor deficiencies in his pawn structure
this pawn on e5 is
is a good is good it's a good pawn
because it's stopping the king from
going to d6
this is a draw this is equal neither
side can really make progress here
so it turns out that you're approaching
this from the wrong
from the wrong side you can
develop a method of avoiding the
perpetual
if you understand that the king can
escape
the checks through this window on g6
so the move g6 comes to mind this is a
way of creating loft
but then there's a further problem and
what rosin talus does
this is the grand master move he has the
same idea
but he plays g5 not g6 and this is the
move
which you'll often see in these kinds of
end games
the key move of this end game which
creates a route for the king via f8 g7
g6 and at the same time fixes white's
king side pawns
that is the key passage it fixes white's
king's side pawns
makes it very hard for white to move
these puns uh
because if he does well g4 drops the
pawn h4 you could simply take it
and come around h3 to win it or you
could go g4
and now fix this weakness on g3
that's a gm pawn move takes boom boom
and uh h5 and black wins h4 g4 this
whole thing happens and ultimately
rosentalis
uh comes after all these pawns right
what happens is that in this position if
if white had gone king e3 after rook g2
king f4 king g6 important move
stopping king g5 black is going to go
rook f2 and rook f3 and just win the g3
point
so this move literally won black the
game and rosentalis eventually just wins
wins both of the pawns and wins the game
yeah so it's it's a complex idea
but there are much simpler applications
of this in the end game when you need to
create loft
you often want to do so while also
fixing your opponent's king side pawns
right and i'll talk more about this
later but
that's the bottom line all right guys i
think that's a great place
to stop it's almost a six hour stream
damn
time has flown by i can't believe it
thank you guys um
i will see you tomorrow uh around the
afternoon
and i want to thank everybody for the
massive support as we hold
together over 6 000 subs that's great
i i'm honored and stuff coming out
on on my youtube continues to come out
on my youtube
would love it if you gave me a sub there
where we
are currently let's see we're currently
at 161 000 subscribers we're aiming for
200k you know sometime in the next in
the next
month two months that would be amazing
so thank you guys
[Music]
you